étranger
[Musique]
tu vas être là toute la nuit
prête Sue
nous avons un spectacle spectaculaire avec des
talents incroyables
papa emmène les enfants à la maison puis
fais attention à Timmy il est mordant Je ne change
pas de couches
le producteur  a dit que les notes
baissaient bien sûr qu'ils vous regardaient les
gars maintenant ew
je suis la blague toujours de la ville
oh Manny tu me complètes
hey Fury appelle Judy oh je ne peux pas obtenir le
mot de passe
scan du visage oh beau sourire la vie était dure
pour les petits mammifères
[  Musique]
bienvenue dans le plus grand concours de talents de zootopia,
alors je vais simplement déplacer cette table ici, cela
pourrait devenir un peu musqué, c'est bien
la famille que vous avez vous rend riche les
amis que vous choisissez font d'eux une famille
vous ne vous sentirez jamais petit
embrassez votre corps  et soyez libre
Je viens de voir qu'un endroit chez un mouton
qui n'a pas de
parents en laine Diffusez-le sur Disney Plus